[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle alix j'ai 40 ans
et je n'aime pas la vie
voilà
vous savez tout sur moi parce que tout
le reste découle de ces trois phrases
d'ailleurs je me demande souvent
pourquoi la première question qu'on pose
quand on rencontre quelqu'un n'est pas
et toi de quel côté tu as pièce est elle
tombée
fais-tu partie de ceux qui m'aiment face
aux circonstances les plus adverse
continueront d'affirmer que l'essentiel
c'est d'être en vie
ou bien de ceux qui même en ayant tout
pour être heureux ou heureuse attendent
avec impatience le clap de fin
car je suis sûr de ne pas être un cas
isolé
il y a même sans doute parmi vous
plusieurs personnes qui doivent chaque
matin déployé des trésors d'énergie pour
accomplir les actions les plus banales
et qui préférerait ne pas être né
mais combien d'entre vous ose le dire
il me semble que dans un pays qui
célèbre les culotté et sans filtre les
grandes gueules on touche là à un des
derniers tabous
il faut aimer la vie
l'adhésion à cette proposition est même
tellement présupposés qu'on ne vous
demande pas votre avis avant de
s'exclamer devant vous il n'ya pas de
plus beau cadeau que de donner la vie
tant qu'il ya de la vie il ya de
l'espoir
pour moi ces affirmations reflète des
opinions personnelles
que je respecte tout en ayant un peu de
mal à les comprendre
mais voilà la vie ne nous demande pas
notre avis tu les aimes ou tu la quittes
personnellement j'ai longtemps
tergiversé sur les moyens de la quitter
j'avais du mal à endosser la
responsabilité de cette décision
et puis pour reprendre la métaphore de
l'idéologie dominante
ça ne se fait pas de rendre un cadeau
donc il ne me restait plus que l'autre
branche de l'alternative
alors arriver à ce stade de mon
intervention j'ai une bonne et une
mauvaise nouvelle pour vous la mauvaise
c'est que je n'ai pas de recette miracle
pour apprendre à aimer la vie
la bonne c'est que la psychiatrie
moderne fait ça extrêmement bien à
condition d'arriver jusqu'à elle
à l'adolescence
j'étais mal dans ma peau
je traversais des épisodes dépressifs
sauf que je ne savais pas encore ce que
c'était
et puis je me trouvais grosses comme
toutes les filles de mon âge
je me souviens très bien du matin où je
me suis dit voilà une chose que je peux
contrôler
je ne peux pas contrôler le cours de ma
vie je ne peux pas forcer les autres à
m'apprécier mais je peux contrôler mon
poids
c'est devenu mon grand projet
l'obsession de la privation a rempli ma
vie
l'anorexie c'est une drogue dure
sous l'effet de la privation de
nourriture votre cerveau se met en mode
survie et vous avez des sortes de shoot
d'adrénaline
c'est totalement addictif
une fois que vous rentrez dans ce cercle
infernal
aucun aliment n'est aussi bon que la
sensation d'être maigre
ce n'est pas de moi c'est du kate moss
pendant longtemps j'ai pensé que j'avais
simplement un problème avec la
nourriture
d'ailleurs le premier médecin que j'ai
consultés pensaient la même chose il m'a
demandé vous fumez non c'est dommage
vous auriez pu prendre une cigarette
plutôt que de vous faire vomir
j'ai aussi consulté des nutritionnistes
qui m'ont fait noter dans des carnets ce
que je mangeais est ce que je mangeais
pas en vain
il m'a fallu du temps pour comprendre
que mon problème ce n'était pas de
manger trop ou pas assez
c'était la vie que je vomissais
au bout de sept ans je suis allé voir
une psychiatre qui m'a mise sous
traitement d'antidépresseurs et petit à
petit j'ai pu mettre de la distance avec
mon addiction et et reprendre confiance
en moi
au début chaque fois que je me sentais
mieux jarret tel traitement
je voulais tenir debout sans béquilles
et puis je replongeais
un jour où je revenais la tête basse
après une énième interruption brutale
mon médecin m'a dit vous savez vous
n'aurez pas de médaille pour arrêter
alors j'en ai pris mon parti
une autre chose qui m'a aidé à sortir de
l'anorexie et de la boulimie c'est
d'apprendre à me servir de mon corps
pendant mes études j'ai commencé à
monter les chevaux de course à chantilly
et j'ai adoré ça
tout à coup mon corps n'était plus ce
truc encombrant que je m'efforçais de
réduire jusqu'à sa plus simple
expression
mais un outil qui pouvait me donner
accès à des sensations magique
pour pouvoir ressentir l'ivresse de la
vitesse sur un pur sang au galop il
fallait que je sois forte il fallait que
je sois en forme
donc il fallait que je nourrisse mon
corps parce que j'en avais besoin pour
accéder à ces sensations qui me faisait
tellement de bien
pendant 11 ans j'ai tous les matins j'ai
pris ce même traitement
d'antidépresseurs mais tous les deux ans
à peu près mon médecin devait augmenter
la posologie pour que le médicament
continue à faire effet
jusqu'au jour où
j'ai senti
que toutes les barrières que j'avais
dressé depuis tout ce temps
entre le suicide et moi
était en train de céder
j'ai demandé à être hospitalisées et on
m'a dit que j'étais atteinte de
mélancolie
la mélancolie en psychiatrie ça n'a rien
de romantique c'est la mélancolie à des
philosophes grecs
étymologiquement la bile noire
tellement noir qu'il n'y a plus d'espoir
on m'a fait essayer toute une batterie
d'antibiotiques
d'anxiolytiques de régulateurs de
l'humeur sous des combinaisons diverses
et des dosages variés
et un matin en me réveillant
j'ai eu la sensation qu'on avait arrêté
de m'enfoncer la tête sous l'eau
en sortant de l'hôpital j'avais les
cheveux blancs et conscience d'avoir eu
beaucoup de chance
une subtile combinaison de molécules
avait réussi à réparer les
dysfonctionnements de mon cerveau
mais j'avais aussi côtoyé beaucoup de
passion qui attendaient depuis des
semaines que quelques choses viennent
soulager leurs angoisses leurs idées
noires
j'avais appris que la mélancolie est
souvent fatale et que 30% des
dépressions ne trouve pas de réponse
thérapeutique
en rentrant à la maison je me suis aussi
rendu compte à travers les réactions de
mes proches que la maladie mentale
continue de faire peur est ce que ces
réactions étaient provoqués par la peur
d'être contaminées par la maladie
ou la honte d'être proches d'une
personne atteinte d'une maladie mentale
sans doute un peu des deux
et pourtant j'ai eu envie de parler de
ce qui m'était arrivé
je sentais confusément que je ne pouvais
pas être seul dans mon cas et que mon
expérience pouvait peut-être servir à
d'autres
donc je me suis mise à en parler assez
librement
malgré les réactions horrifiées de mes
proches qui me disaient mais alors tu
leur as dit que tu étais dingo
à force de m'intéresser à ces questions
je suis tombé un jour sur une annonce
une offre d'emploi un peu particulière
il y avait deux critères pour postuler
avait être bac + 2 et avoir fait un
séjour en hôpital psychiatrique
je me suis dit pour une fois je coche
toutes les cases
aujourd'hui j'accompagne des personnes
atteintes de troubles psychiques
en m'appuyant sur ma propre expérience
de malade rétabli on dit rétabli et pas
guéri parce que c'est un processus
permanent comme un funambule dont
l'équilibré perpétuellement instable
concrètement ça veut dire que je suis
toujours sous traitement que je le serai
toute ma vie et que je continue d'être
suivi par des thérapeutes notamment pour
veiller à ce que rendre service prendre
soin des autres ne me porte pas
préjudice
mais ça ne m'empêche pas d'être reconnu
pour ce que je suis et ce que je fais je
peux être à la fois soigné et soignante
sur ma blouse il est écrit médiatrice
père et ir eux donc c'est officiel tout
le monde sait que je suis dingue ou et
c'est exactement pour ça qu'on fait
appel à moi je trouve que c'est un beau
message de vivre ensemble
je me suis aussi formé à un autre type
de médiation qui fait appel à mon
compagnon de toujours le cheval
la médiation équine ça consiste pour le
patient a projeté sur le cheval sa
vision de ces troubles c'est une
thérapie très puissante notamment pour
les gens qui ont du mal à mettre des
mots sur leurs souffrances
pour vous donner un exemple je voudrais
vous parler d'une jeune femme que j'ai
reçus lors d'une de mes toutes premières
séances
cette jeune femme choisit un cheval
parfaitement calme le conduit dans
l'espace réservé aux séances
aussitôt le cheval se met à galoper à
droite à gauche à hennir comme un perdu
elle me dit il n'est pas bien ici je
vais le conduire ailleurs la scène se
reproduit dans un deuxième espace je
vois l'anxiété croître sur le visage de
la patiente au fur et à mesure qu'elle
déplace le cheval qui ne se calme pas et
puis tout à coup le cheval point de ses
oreilles dans une direction
la patiente qui conduit trouve un autre
cheval
immédiatement le sien s'apaise et se
mettent à manger de l'herbe
il ya plusieurs façons de considérer ce
qui s'est elle mène ensuite raconté
je suis bipolaire et bisexuels donc le
fait de ne pas me sentir à ma place
d'être tiraillé c'est l'histoire de ma
vie
et le cheval vient de me montrer que le
seul moyen de trouver la paix c'est de
me réconcilier avec cette autre part de
moi même que j'ai relégué hors de ma vie
il ya plusieurs façons de considérer ce
qui s'est passé pour cette jeune femme
certains diront que le cheval est entré
en empathie avec elle au point de jouer
consciemment la scène qu'elle a vécu
d'autres diront que c'est en observant
le cheval à travers le prisme de ses
troubles
qu'elle a construit le récit dont elle
avait besoin
en fait peu m'importe dans les deux cas
le cheval a servi de support à un récit
qui a permis à la patiente de donner un
sens à ce qu'elle vit et entrevoir le
sens de ces troubles c'est le début du
rétablissement
à ce propos je dois vous remercier
être devant vous ce soir on a permis de
structurer mon propre récit et de
l'exprimer
savez vous que le sens premier du verne
exprimer ses extraire d'un corps le
liquide qu'il contient d'où expression
en m'exprimant devant vous ce soir j'ai
extrait de mon corps la bile noire
la mélancolie
soyez en remerciés
[Applaudissements]